[Musique]
et
il était une fois un vieux roi qui
régnait sur une île une île magnifique
ce roi avait un jeune fils qui
s'appelait le prince henri marie
françois dit pierre antoine
c'était un nom bien long pour un si
petit prince
aussi quand il était enfant on
l'appelait ce blog chaque matin au lieu
de se débarbouiller dans un lavabo ce
qui est mortellement ennuyeux le prince
bleu ballet se baigner nu dans la mer et
chaque matin il retrouvait une sirène
avec laquelle il jouait depuis qu'il
était petit
quand tu seras grand j'ai posera une
belle princesse qui aura deux jambes
comme tout le monde et non une vilaine
queue de poisson et du succédera au roi
ton père n'en disait le prince jeunes
épouserait que toi aujourd'hui j'ai 15
ans je t'aime toujours et je veux
t'épouser cette fois la sirène de vin
poussive mais ces mariages sont toujours
malheureux tu changerais et deux jambes
pour une queue de poisson
tu regretteras la vie mortelle la terre
est ton enfance
mais moi je t'aime disait le prince et
je suis sûr de ne rien regretter jamais
le père de blogs ayant appris que son
fils avait une sirène à la s'enquérir
auprès de l'aumônier du palais
mais c'est une catastrophe s'écrit à
l'aumônier les sirènes sont des démons
le prince en l'épousant deviendrait en
daim et n'aurait plus de gens mais une
queue de poisson
il ne pourrait jamais vous succéder il
faut les séparer
ton père de nous séparer blob ne crée
arias je suis immortel
si l'on nous sépare quand tu voudras me
retrouver mais toi dans un endroit où il
ya de l'eau douce ou salée
il te suffira alors de chanter un et
affronte ainsi ré de mamie je suis votre
ondins vous êtes ma vie le lendemain le
roi 20 à la plage accompagné de nombreux
notables dissimulant sous leurs habits
de cour des cordes des filets des
matraques et des révolvers aller à ce
signal hill se jetèrent sur la sirène et
la prière dans leurs filets le prince
blog qui voulait la défendre fut
lui-même assailli avant d'avoir pu faire
un geste en porter moi ce monstre hurla
le roi est coupé lui la queue en
tranches pour la vendre au marché
quant à vous mon fils je vous envoie
chez mon cousin l'empereur de russie
loin de l'océan et de cet amour idiot
[Musique]
je t'aime rien font ainsi rennes mamie
je suis votre mandat vous êtes ma vie
bonjour 13 club tu m'aimes encore je
t'aime à rien font ainsi rennes mamie je
suis votre mandat vous êtes ma vie
bonjour presse claude tu m'aimes encore
[Musique]
un jour l'empereur fit savoir au prince
blob que désormais ils n'auraient plus
le droit de se laver mon chef 12
j'ai fait ce que j -p mais il est
impossible d'empêcher votre fils
d'évoquer cette sirène
je vous le renvoi et que dieu vous garde
signé nikita premier empereur de l'union
le royaume uni allure cette lettre il
n'y avait plus qu'une solution
transformer le prince un timbre poste et
le coller au mur à l'endroit le plus sec
du palais afin que pose une goutte d'eau
ni touche après kadabra qui devient tout
plein braquer d'abris tu deviens
tout-petits abracadabra tu deviens
papier bras cadavres en de papier
collant petit désobéissent leroy regarda
le timbre de près ces demandes a blob
s'il voulait toujours épouser sa sirène
oui je le veux toujours répondre est une
voie de papier les jours les semaines
les mois passèrent oui je le veux
répondait toujours le timbre blob
[Musique]
fuji lieu un cyclone venant de la mer
mais le palais royal était bien bâti et
pas une goutte d'eau ne parvint au
bureau du bois résidus la guerre et
quand le roi et la reine remontèrent de
la carde le palais comme un seul le roi
à poil et pénétra dans son bureau un
verre d'eau à la main les flammes dans
ces de toutes parts le roi embrassa le
timbre en pleurant sois heureux mon
petit puis voulu jeter le verre d'eau
sur le timbre est le timbre avait
disparu une larme du roi l'avait mouillé
blob avait enfin rejoint saint cyr année
peu après une terrible nouvelle la
flotte ennemie étaient signalés les
bateaux avançait mais soudain autour de
la mer se mit à onduler elle se
remplissaient de choses bizarres une
nageoire n'attend qu'une que tordu une
nouvelle ouverte la flotte ennemie
semblait voguer sur une mer de 9 au bout
d'une demi heure la flotte ennemie et
est entièrement détruit ben lobb et la
sirène du royaume le roi était heureux
ou du moins presque heureux
la paix règne sur l'île mais lille
restait sans prince et le roi sans
enfant si ce n'est que cela pense à la
sirène je vais tout arranger baignez
vous sur la plage d'utah le roi avec sa
majesté la reine
quand vous verrez un poisson d'argent
qui viendra jouer autour de vous laisser
le faire n'ayez pas peur de lui et dans
huit jours vous aurez un petit garçon
une semaine plus tard il avait un petit
prince
oui tout ça se passait il ya bien
longtemps aujourd'hui le pressent blob
est toujours anodin ses parents eux sont
morts bien entendu mais leur petit
enfant règne encore sur l'île heureuse
et aucune flotte ennemie n'ose venir les
attaquer
[Musique]